10 rounds central target in your own
time fire
these ukrainian recruits have one aim
to become a soldier as fast as possible
perhaps surprisingly though they've come
to a military base in the uk to learn
the british trainers here are highly
skilled
but more importantly this shooting range
in north west england is free from the
threat of russian missiles
when we
prepare
go to the ukraine to uk
we have to attack from
from russia and from belarus sides to
our position when we train our our
soldier
and it's we always ready to
russian bombs and russia invasion when
we when we're training the recruits and
their commanders asked not to be
identified
most have left civilian jobs to join the
military in recent days
they're borrowing british uniforms while
here as they don't yet have their own
everything has changed since february
24th and i took my time to make sure my
family and relatives are safe but right
now i'm ready to stand among all our
other folks and do my best to protect
everything that
is available for me
this sense of duty runs strong
the recruits work from dawn until late
at night every day
through ukrainian interpreters they're
taught how to handle a weapon first aid
skills and how to survive outdoors
many of these new recruits hadn't even
touched a weapon a few weeks ago now
they're on this firing range shooting at
targets some 200 meters away and the
trainers here tell me that they very
often hit
this is an intense wartime infantry
course of just a few weeks compared to
the six months given to a regular
british recruit
the uk has pledged to train around 10
000 ukrainians in 120 days
a vital pipeline given ukraine is losing
up to 200 soldiers a day to the war
who's the best shot so far the defense
secretary and potential contender for
prime minister paid the training ground
a visit on thursday
it's one of four being used across the
country we're not identifying the
precise location for security reasons
training matters when you're in a war
and you're against the russia you need
to make sure that you can be as best as
you can be and that's this is the
process we're doing here we're starting
to deliver that the british trainers say
they're making a difference but some
would clearly like to be doing that in
ukraine rather than remotely 100
it's it's well unfortunately it's not up
to me but i would love to go out there
with them they are we see them as
brothers in arms here teaching these
recruits to shoot straight though is
still a valuable gift as they prepare to
fight for real
debra haynes sky news in northwest
england